بعض الدراسات في جامعه جورج تاون اكدت ان
معدلات الاكتئاب والقلق لدى البشر معرضه
للارتفاع تخيلوا بمجرد زياده الحراره درجه
واحده فقط اكثر من المعتاد فيما يعرف باسم
الاكتئاب الصيفي وفق الدراسه الحراره تؤثر
على الناقل العصبي الذي يساهم في تنظيم
حاله المزاج للانسان
تتمثل ايضا والقلق والذي قد يصل في بعض
الاحيان الى نوبات اكتئاب بينما يستعد
العالم لمواجهه موجات حراره جديده السؤال
هنا كيف نحمي صحتنا النفسيه من حراره
الصيد الحارقه
[موسيقى]
دكتوره الحقيقه يعني نتائج هاي الدراسه
بالنسبه الي ما كانت كتير مفاجئه لانه انا
انسان بعاني كل صيف فعلا من انخفاض في
المزاج العام ويعني بلاش نقول اكتئاب ولكن
نوع من انواع نزول هيك في نفسيتي والان
طلع عن جد انه فعلا كيف الحراره ممكن تؤثر
على جسمنا وعلى ايضا صحتنا النفسيه لازم
نبقى عارفين ان في حاجه اسمها السيزون
الافيكتيف ديس اوردر سمر او الريفر
المزاج الموسمي العكسي او الصيف لان
العاده
المعتقد او المعتاد عليه ان هو بيجي في
فصل الشتاء نوبات من الاكتئاب بالضبط
في الدول بتختفي عنها الشمس تماما فبيزيد
الاكتئاب الا ان في 10% من الناس بيجيلهم
اكتئاب الريفيرس العكسي اللي هو بيجي في
الصيف لازم نبقى عارفين ههه
كلنا نبقى عارفين ان في درجات من
الحبات زي ما انت بتقولي كده مش نوصله
لمرحله الحزن والاكتئاب بس هي بس انخفاض
في المزاج في بعض الناس بتحس بالعصبيه
شويه التوتر لان هم لقوا ان درجه الحراره
لما بتزيد عن 20 بيبتدي يشعر للناس ده لما
بتزيد درجه عن 20 بنبتدي نشعر بعدم
الارتياح لا لازم نعيش
لازم نعيش في القطب الشمالي احساس بسيط
بعدم الارتياح فكلما زادت اكتر بقى ال 28
وبعدين 30 بيشعر الانسان
في الخمسين
انفعال والعصبيه هل هذا يبرر الى انه
عصبيه مثلا سكان هذه المناطق في الخليج
وبعض المناطق في الصحراء في المغرب العربي
وغيرها من انه الجو حار فيعكس مزاجيتهم
وعصبيتهم يبرر ذلك مش يبرر بس هي فكره انه
لقوا ان الدول القريبه من خط الاستواء
اللي هو الصيف بيبقى فيها غالب بيزيد
الاشخاص اللي عندهم الاكتئاب الصيفي ليه
لان بيبقى نسبه النهار طويله ونسبه التعرض
للشمس اكتر فبنسبه الحراره اعلى الرطوبه
اعلى الحاجات دي اللي هي الشبكيه بتاثر
على بتمتص اشعه الشمس تاثر على الساعه
البيولوجيه في الجسم اللي هي السوبرا
كاريزماتيك
تتاثر بيبتدي افرازات الهرمونات نفسه
يتلخبط الميلاتونين بيقل فبالتالي النوم
بيقل فالارق بيزيد وده بيعمل برده اضطراب
في المزاج الكورتيزون بيعلى جدا وده هرمون
القلق والتوتر والاكتئاب وفي علاقه طرديه
لما بيزيد الكورتيزون بيقل السيرتون اللي
هو الهرمون المسؤول عن اعتدال المزاج
هرمون السعاده
[موسيقى]